now let's build a Pinterest clone first
let's take a look at a cool Pinterest
clone that Ashley built so the theme of
her Pinterest was winter Asst the notion
of awesome victories and you can even
watch this video that'll explain kind of
how she came up with the idea so let's
go ahead and login we can connect with
Twitter and now it's redirecting me back
and here we go we see some wins that are
popping up here so let's go ahead and
see if we can create one of our own so
if we go to our win board we see that
I've already created two of these and
I'm gonna add a win so what that means
is I'm going to need a URL so let's
think of something that's really cool a
winner is you this is a cool meme from
some old video game it's just like
really bad grammar
so we'll just copy the image URL and it
winner is you will paste the link here
you can see how quickly a fish that is
great then we choose image video is
eventually going to be supported you can
see it shows up right there in my
opinion and it even swapped the position
of these two which is pretty cool now we
can go ahead and look at all the recent
lens and we can see that my new win is
right here pretty cool huh so I can go
and I can like other people's wins so I
can like this US World Cup team the
Women's World Cup team they just won
we can like and unlike other things too
so it's pretty cool and let's take a
look at the user stories first as an
unauthenticated user I can login with
Twitter as an authenticated user I can
link to images which we did as an
authenticated user I can delete images
that I've linked to and as an
authenticated user I can see a Pinterest
style wall of all the images I've linked
to and as an authenticated user I can
browse other users walls of images I
don't need to be authenticated for that
so basically it's kind of like a public
Pinterest file very similar to Pinterest
much of the same functionality and as a
bonus user story as an authenticated
user if I upload an image that is broken
it will be replaced by a placeholder
image and you can do this with jQuery
broken image detection quick hint Masons
masonry j/s is an excellent library that
will allow for you to have the Pinterest
out grids where different objects of
different heights fit and it's kind of
like breaking it it's a sequence of
breaks like you see on Pinterest or like
you saw here I'll my interest just make
sure that you see that see how these are
different height and it kind of figures
out what to put where and make it look
reasonably good that is masonry j/s so I
think you can have a lot of fun with
this choose a cool theme make it fun and
we're looking forward to seeing it enjoy